and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber we want to get
right to some new developments five
former police officers are facing murder
charges out in Tennessee the district
attorney in Memphis says that all five
played a major role in the death of the
and the death of a man they were
arresting tadarius being Demetrius Haley
Desmond Mills Jr Emmett Martin III and
Justin Smith are all accused of multiple
felonies now the charges in the grand
jury indictment include second-degree
murder aggravated assault aggravated
kidnapping and official misconduct
family members of Tyree Nichols watch
police video of their son's arrest from
earlier this month that landed him in
the hospital for days before he died
they say the officers beat Nichols for
three straight minutes now at the time
of the incident police had only said
that there was a confrontation between
officers and Nichols when he ran from
them during a traffic stop for reckless
driving authorities plan to release the
video to the public on Friday
we can't imagine the pain you're
experiencing
but let me reaffirm
we are here
to pursue truth
and justice
realizing
that we should not be here
simply put this shouldn't have happened
I've been policing for more than 30
years
I've devoted my life to this profession
and I'm grieved
frankly I'm shocked
I'm sickened by what I saw
and what we've learned through our
extensive and thorough investigation
I've seen the video
and as Diego morally stated you will too
in a word it's absolutely appalling
let me be clear
what happened here
does not at all reflect proper policing
this was wrong
this was Criminal
all right here with my co-host Brian
buckmeyer Terry Austin Brian will start
with you why second-degree murder and
not first and given that what kind of
prison time could they be facing yeah so
Jesse the major difference is first
degree murder premeditated and
intentional second-degree murder
knowingly at least that's the way that
Tennessee puts it and I think it's
easier to get that knowing charge here
in a case like this because at least the
fact that we know so far traffic stop
altercation run second altercation I
think that'd be difficult for a
prosecutor to prove that this was
premeditated I think it was more of a
snapshot type of situation but knowingly
does work because that just means
intelligently consciously or willfully
and if they are convicted of that
second-degree murder they're looking at
anywhere from 15 to 60 6-0 years in jail
Terry officers have been fired they've
been charged with murder do you think
the Department of Justice should now get
involved well they just might get
involved here in the past the doj has
investigated different cities when they
think there might be a pattern and
practice of bad police behavior and
we've seen that obviously in Minneapolis
for the George Floyd case where we saw
Derek chovin get convicted right after
that mayor Garland said I am going to
investigate and these are constitutional
civil rights cases they're looking at
whether or not they're violations to
First fourth or even the 14th Amendment
and so they probably will I mean we've
seen it in Minneapolis as I said we've
seen it in Louisville we've seen it in
Phoenix we could there were five people
here how could all five of these
individuals not know what the policy
should be and do these kind of heinous
crime without thinking about you know
what the practice and policies are for
their Police Department yeah this is
going to be a case that we're going to
continue to follow As It ultimately
progresses still ahead on Long crime
daily even more shocking developments in
the case of a six-year-old who shot a
teacher inside of a classroom teachers
say they warn the school's
Administration that something bad Could
Happen three different times but first
audio from the body cam of the first
officer on scene at the Murdoch Family
Estate gives us an idea of the horror
show that investigators
too
[Music]
hey welcome back everybody long crime
daily is bringing you gavel to gavel
coverage of the Murdoch murder mystery
in South Carolina on Thursday prosecutor
Creighton Waters called up the first
witness Sergeant Daniel Green of the
Colleton County Sheriff's Office was the
first officer to respond to one of the
Murdoch homes on June 7th 2021. Alec
Murdock called 9-1-1 after he says he
found his wife Maggie and his son Paul
on the ground and bleeding near a part
of the property used as a dog kennel
Greene walked to the court through much
of the body camera footage the
prosecution highlighted things like tire
tracks bullet casings and Murdoch's
demeanor on that night but on
cross-examination the defense honed in
on the St on the steps law enforcement
took to preserve the crime scene saying
that evidence could have been damaged or
destroyed murdocht openly wept at the
defense table during much of the
testimony while Sergeant Green testified
that Murdoch was upset on the night of
the murderers he didn't appear to shed
any years now while we're allowed to
film the defendant the lawyers the judge
the witnesses we are not allowed to film
The Body camera or the video or the
exhibits which are often very graphic
and disturbing
yesterday they've already checked them
yes sir that's what it looks like
When You observe these victims was it
obvious that they had injuries
incompatible with life yes any
reasonable person that came upon those
bodies would have come to a conclusion
that they were deceased
all right we want to give you a quick
recap of what the prosecution and the
defense had to say during opening
statements on Wednesday both sides were
relatively brief while laying out what
we can expect to see in here over the
next few weeks
listen to that Gathering storm that all
came to a head on June 7th 2021 the day
the evidence will show he killed Maggie
and Paul
this has been a long exhaustive
investigation
it's going to be a fairly long trial
because it's complicated
it's a journey
there's a lot of aspects to this case
there's a lot of factors in this case
but like a lot of things that are
complicated
and you start to put them all together
and piece them together like a puzzle
all of a sudden the picture emerges and
it's really simple
Murdoch's attorney dick harputlian says
that the state's case is just smoking
mirrors and says that he wants to ask
the judge to allow the jury to travel to
the Murdoch property to see the estate
for themselves while the request hasn't
come yet he painted a picture for the
jury during his opening
the night he comes home and finds his
wife and son Butcher and when I say
butchered you're going to see these
photographs when I see them now after
having seen them for the last
four or five months it still shocks me
it still is tough to look at it's still
bothers me
and he comes home and finds his son
laying in his own blood with his brain
laying at his feet
shot to hell
he walks over he checks to see if
there's any light there although I mean
he's seeing his brain laying outside his
body he knows there's nothing there he
goes over and tries to get a pulse out
of Maggie no pulse there calls 9-1-1 I
want you to hear that 9-1-1 take it is a
man hysterical in grief
trying to trying to figure out what's
going on
Brian why put the first responder on as
the initial witness I mean what do you
think that was so helpful that he
provided to the jury so Jesse I would
say it's kind of like a tree right this
witness gives us the roots of the case
that's the first person at the scene
they're seeing where uh Murdoch put his
shotgun when he drove back and and the
tired tracks and where the blood was and
where the bodies were and how Murdoch
initially reacted from there every one
of those points we're going to hear a
witness testify about these issues but
it's good for the jury to be grounded in
this first responder so they're almost
getting introduced in this case the same
way the prosecutor did and then from
there they'll grow the case and they'll
be able to pick apart
um the defense is come oh sorry they'll
be able to pick apart where the defense
is going to argue but also the defense
against that pick apart their arguments
at each step as this kind of tree
branches out and let's talk about that
because Terry the defense conducted a
very detailed cross-examination of the
sergeant what point stood out to you
that they were trying to make well
Ryan's right I I think the defense is
trying to pick apart the prosecution's
case and all he has to do is make some
Reasonable Doubt and he had two really
good theories I think one of the
theories is that Paul shot himself and
then he shot his mother and there were
brains on the ceiling and in fact when
the investigators first came there
that's what they thought happened and
Sergeant Green actually said yep that's
what we thought at first the second
theory that I think is a good theory is
the fact that someone related to the
boat incident where Mallory Beach died
might have had some Vengeance and wanted
to come back and to kill Paul and he
established that during that
cross-examination because that was the
first thing that Alec said to him when
he got on the scene all right so we're
starting from the beginning and it'll
slowly make its way through I encourage
everyone out there to stay with us for
gavel to gavel coverage of this high
profile trial you can check out links to
videos live streams from the courtroom
all on lawncrime.com
and coming up on Long crime daily a
holocaust Survivor meets a woman online
and ends up falling victim to a
disturbing crime plus teachers say
School administrators had at least three
warnings that a young student might harm
others before he shot his teacher in the
chest those details up next
the Educators shot by a six-year-old
student in her first grade classroom
says all of this could have been
prevented because teachers warned school
officials that that little boy had had a
weapon her attorney had this message
see Abby and these other teachers at
Richmond Elementary School tried to do
the right thing on January 6th the day
of the shooting
on that day over the course of a few
hours
three different times
three times School administration was
warned by concerned teachers and
employees that the boy had a gun on him
at the school
and was threatening people but the
administration could not be bothered
this tragedy was entirely preventable
if the school administrators responsible
for school safety had done their part
and taken action when they had knowledge
of imminent danger
but instead they failed to act and Abby
was shot
when that six-year-old boy shot
Abigail's Werner the bullet went through
her hand and into her chest now luckily
she's out of the hospital but she does
have a very long road to recovery her
attorney says that the administration
downplayed the threat from the student
at least three different times in fact
at one point a school official told a
teacher that he likely didn't take a gun
out to recess because his pockets are
too small to put it in the boy's parents
say he has an acute disability and that
the gun was secured with a trigger lock
on Wednesday the school board voted to
fire school district superintendent
George Parker III Ryan three times three
times the school was supposedly worn and
three times they apparently did nothing
seems like a pretty open and shut case
after that no it does but what I need to
hear is what exactly was relayed to
these teachers or administrators and
what steps did they take we also need to
look at the school's protocols for how
they're supposed to address this I can
figure that there's going to be
protocols at a high school or a college
I understand this is a middle school
maybe they don't have those in place
maybe they're not thinking about
six-year-olds having a gun maybe they
just thought hey this is a joke this is
a hyperbole this can't be true because
we're all sitting here thinking this
can't be true how do we have a
six-year-old shooting a teacher but we
see the injuries we see the wounds we
know what happened and now we have to
ask the hard questions what policies
were in place and why were they
overlooked Terry a couple of those
administrators they've left they've been
asked they're the positions I'm curious
why they're leaving because are they
trying to protect themselves from being
included in a civil lawsuit well they
can try but it's not going to help as
you said we know that the superintendent
was voted out he was asked that he was
kicked out there was also an assistant
principal who actually just left she
decided I'm leaving and if she did it
because she thought she could protect
herself from any sort of civil liability
it's not going to work first of all if
she was one of the people who ignored
those warnings then she could be held
negligent for those actions it wasn't
reasonable under those circumstances for
her to ignore the warnings if she was
involved the other issue as far as the
school is concerned is the fact that
were these teachers trained Brian
mentioned it what are the protocols I
believe they should have had protocols
in place even though it is an elementary
school the fact that you could have
someone bring a gun in whether it's a
student an administrator a parent a
strain danger you need to be ready for
anything that happens especially with
all of the shootings across the country
yeah it makes absolutely no sense and
from what we're hearing just taking this
is true maybe could have been prevented
police say a man plowed his pickup truck
through the front doors of their Police
Department Wednesday on purpose you have
to take a look at this video the crash
happened around lunchtime in Grand
Junction Colorado and you can see the
truck hits the retaining wall on the
other side of the lobby now at the time
11 employees were behind that wall an
officer ordered the driver out at
gunpoint and was taken into custody
without any injuries the driver Nathan
chicone told police that he thought he
was being followed and thought that his
best bet for protection was to drive
into the police department unbelievable
there well we have new updates from
Fayetteville Arkansas where the CFO of
Tyson Foods drunkenly broke into a
woman's home and slept in her bed
all right
put your hands behind the back
no hands behind your back yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo
this isn't your house
hands behind your back you're under
arrest yeah that's not great uh John R
Tyson pleaded guilty this week to public
intoxication and criminal trespassing
charges back in November a woman found
the 32 year old executive asleep in her
bed around 2 A.M she called police to
report an intruder thinking that her
front door might have been left unlocked
While She Was Out officer said Tyson was
mostly unresponsive at the scene and
smelled very strongly of alcohol after
his arrest Tyson told investigators
quote I'm embarrassed this was an
incident inconsistent with our company
values as well as my personal values
he's required to pay a total of 440
dollars in fines and fees I'm sure he
can afford it well we have a police
officer under investigation in Wyandotte
Michigan after the department says
there's been an incident of stealing at
the station earlier this month the
police officer was eating lunch in the
break room when he was asked to help his
colleague with someone in jail I was
half eaten sandwich was left on the
table when the officer came back to the
break room another colleague walked out
licking his lips licking his chops uh oh
and the sandwich had mysteriously
vanished after reviewing the evidence
they charged K-9 Officer I say known
repeat offender with the crime the
department says that he's invoked his
Fifth Amendment right to remain silent
completely understand that but some fans
on Facebook sent officer ice his very
own sandwich
when we come back a much darker story a
holocaust Survivor loses his life
savings at the hands of a scammer we'll
look at the lies that made one woman a
millionaire
foreign
[Music]
everybody we end Today's Show with a
disturbing story out of Florida a
holocaust Survivor was swindled out of
nearly 3 million dollars during a
years-long romance scam the 87 year old
Manhattan man met Peach's sturgo on a
dating site six years ago the 36 year
old who also goes by the name Alice
asked the victim for money starting in
2017. she claimed that she won a lawsuit
settlement but just you know needed help
covering legal fees the series of Lies
would continue for more than four years
Sturgill purchased two properties
multiple cars a boat expensive watches
all with the money Sturgill even sent
the victim fake Bank invoices to make it
look like she was paying him back a
total of 62 checks were deposited in
sturgo's account until 2021 when the
victim told his son that he gave his
life savings to Sturgill who promised
that she would pay him back Sergo was
arrested Wednesday in a federal charge
of wire from broad Terry what a terrible
case I mean romance scans they're
they're on the rise you research the FTC
website what advice do they provide to
avoid being scammed well it's increasing
so much that they did provide advice on
their website it's over 200 million
dollars lost last year they say what you
should do is look out for certain types
of profiles so if you see someone who
says they are an international figure
that they have to travel a lot or if you
have a picture one of the things you can
do is a reverse image on that picture
and if in fact another name comes up you
know that that is not the right person
and they're saying that what they want
to ask for is Cash they don't just say
write me a check or you know other ways
that money can be traced they try to get
money in ways that cannot be traced so
they ask for gift cards or wired through
something like some federal wiring you
know company but you know what they say
you need to do is to be very careful
older people are often targeted on these
sites and if you have a family member
who is older make sure you take care of
those individuals and have them double
check before they actually go on to
these sites Brian the great thing is we
present always both sides in this kit in
our stories the victim wrote the checks
for Sturgill can't he just can't the
defense say that these were gifts to his
girlfriend
not really because Jesse it comes down
to coercion as well as false promises
that's where it becomes wrong but that's
not really what she's being charged is
the wire fraud if the moving of the
funds across state lines through false
information now this story like Terry
said it's dangerous many people should
be on the lookout it makes me very happy
that I am happily married and not dating
anymore but watch out for people like
this because they can coerce you into
spending your life-saving away and you
better hope that the police can catch
him unbelievable you don't think that a
holocaust Survivor has had a hard enough
life now has to deal with this Brian
Terry thanks so much everyone thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
foreign